President Trump is defending his
criticism of the late Senator John
McCain saying he was never a fan of
McCain and never will be the president
doubled down on his recent Twitter
attacks when he was asked about McCain
in the Oval Office yesterday the Arizona
Republican died seven months ago from a
brain tumor
Paula Reid is at the White House with
what's behind the feud and Paula so many
people are just saying why continue to
do this exactly a one-sided fight with a
dead man on Twitter would seem to have a
little upside for the leader of the free
world and beyond a yesterday in the Oval
Office he was asked what many of us have
been wondering why are you doing this I
was never a fan of John McCain and I
never will be President Trump continued
to attack his political foil even in
death one reason he cites for his
continued grievance thermic machines
July 2017 vote against a Republican
effort to repeal the Affordable Health
Care Act very unhappy that he didn't
repeal and replace Obamacare as you know
he campaigned on repealing in a place
replacing Obamacare for years and then
he got to a vote and he said thumbs down
I think that's disgraceful plus there
are other things over the weekend the
president attacked McCain on Twitter
noting incorrectly that he was last in
his class at the u.s. Naval Academy
drawing a strong rebuke for McCain's
daughter Megan a host on ABC's The View
I just thought your life is spent on
your weekends not with your family not
with your friends but obsessing
obsessing over great men you could never
live up to yeah that tells you
everything you need to know about his
pathetic life right yeah it's a feud
that goes back to 2015 when then
candidate Trump said this he's a war
hero because he was captured
I like people that weren't captured in
response to the president's remarks
Tuesday senator MIT Romney tweeted I
can't understand why the president would
once again disparage a man as exemplary
as my friend John McCain and McCain's
Widow Cindy shared this attack she
received on Twitter from a user who said
she's glad McCain is dead the president
also escalated another spat with a
living target calling the husband of one
of his top advisors Kellyanne
a total loser now George Conway a
prominent conservative attorney here in
Washington has repeatedly insulted the
President on Twitter and recently
questioned his mental health Gayle boy
Thank You Paula